[Applause]
everybody
they're very excited
thank you so much welcome back I'm so
happy to beat that it's been a minute
since you've been here but I did my mom
was like who did you say hi to when you
were on the Emmys and I was like I don't
even know if you knew but I just saw you
and I was like oh hey are you wearing
white right you were saying yes you
didn't even know but I was just like I
just looked out and I just saw you and I
was like well I guess I'll say hi
you I don't know why I walked in and out
I literally walked on stage and walked
out my dress was actually riding up the
entire time so a lot of people saw
something they didn't want to see so I'm
so sorry I didn't I was I was on stage I
literally walked out to present an award
and I'd come from another job so I
literally walked in the building and
walked on the stage of the door and I
was like oh there she and you look so
you were so radiant like in that white
dress it was so beautiful thank you so
much yeah you like stuck out to me thank
you but you've had a big life change
since then you turned 30 right yes
that's awesome
is it a fun party did you plan it yeah I
never throw myself parties and I thought
I should good right because it's 30.
yeah and I fully enjoyed it but I think
I've been really enjoying the process of
being 30 and
you know learning to put up with things
that I can and and just caring about who
I surround myself with it's been kind of
a journey 100 pick the weeds keep the
flowers yes that's what I say I feel
like too also and I I found myself
saying I watched your documentary with
my mom and my sister and we were they're
visiting and I was like oh I want to
watch this thing I was like she's coming
on watching that it reminded me of
several relationships and friendships in
my life and I feel like friendships have
seasons and that's not a bad thing I
feel like people can come in and out of
your lives at different times and I I
felt like do you feel similar to that
yeah they're actually I mean we started
shooting this in 2016 and there are
people in that dock that are no longer
in my life because that was the right
thing to do yeah and not necessarily a
bad thing either way I always feel like
it's one of those things where it's like
we're all on different like paths and
it's okay that we didn't meet up right
now yeah because we might meet up again
later yeah or not yeah or not no I have
those things too where it's like you
don't realize that's I I think was so
triggered because my mom and sister were
just like wow you two are somewhere and
I was like okay
um I was like loud and clear
um but it was it was just one of those
things I thought I think when people
watch this they're gonna feel like a big
sister with you like and be like wait
wait you want to just hold you and you
want to cuddle because you're very open
about everything in the documentary
about your health about the highs and
lows it's not like some depressing it's
a lot of things all the emotions but I
thought that it was really cool that you
were so open about I mean having lupus
about bipolar disorder about going to
speak what was that like speaking of
this is amazing I went to the McLean
Hospital and it's one of the best
hospitals for
um all I mean they are they're kind of
covering everything in the mental health
space and so I was able to
say my diagnosis out loud for the first
time and it just it gave me such
strength and it really it wasn't easy
and I think that's why I wanted the
documentary to feel really personal but
I'm kind of scared like a lot of people
are gonna see
this whole other side of me and I'm like
hope they like it I think it's
refreshing I think it's nice because
it's such a filtered world like and
we're different Generations so it's just
like it's I feel like your age and
younger like it's just such a a
different world where everybody filters
everything online and that's not live
that's not real life like everybody has
things right and I just thought it was
very powerful like to not know what was
happening with you but you knew
something was wrong you sought out help
and you got it and that's that's going
to help so many people that watch this I
hope so yes whether it's depression or
Whatever anxiety like whatever it's like
it really does you watch it you go okay
wait I do Vibe with that like that's
similar to me so it's it's gonna I think
awaken a lot of people I hope so because
I'm really nervous was it nervous for
you because in the and right after you
spoke at that hospital all those people
like afterwards like talking to you do
you ever feel the weight of that like
when they're telling you their story
because I feel like a lot of people will
tell us things that maybe they should
put up like someone that's trained yeah
that knows what to say back yeah I'm
definitely not a professional but it was
really I think I'm more so connect with
people that have been on a similar
journey and I don't mind having those
conversations with people again I
anything that I do I want it to be some
sort of light in the world so yeah I'm
excited that people will get to see you
know how how much it paid off to be
honest with my story yeah because it's
freeing it feels freeing when you're
finally like nope this is me and this is
how it is and yes I loved how you were
in Kenya like I loved how it was it was
different to watch you and even having
conversations with these girls and like
your many Revelations like with these
girls like asking about guys that one
conversation yes what was her name Betty
Betty and she is unbelievable and um I
basically went on a trip and we were
there with an organization but this
young woman who is younger than me just
spoke so candidly about her own mental
health struggles and it was really
incredible to be all the way aside on
the other side of the world and and see
how people handle these things and how
you know people don't talk about it but
she was just so beautiful and her story
is really great if you do get to watch
it it's beautiful yeah I loved I love
that conversation at the table and
everything it was just nice to see you
in that moment and I thought that was
really cool
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]